[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend wir sind live
mit zdf heute live monate lang hieß es
von seiten der politik eine impfpflicht
gegen das corona virus wird es nicht
geben und gestern abend sagt bald
bundeskanzler scholz im zdf heute
journal dass wir haben es nicht
geschafft dass ausreichend viele
bürgerinnen und bürger sich geimpft
haben sehr viele haben das und weil es
aber nicht genug sind ist es so dass wir
in der lage sind in der wir heute uns
befinden und deshalb ist es richtig dass
wir sagen unter diesen umständen kann
und muss eine solche entscheidung
getroffen denn ich bin dafür ich bin
aber auch dafür dass das auf basis von
entscheidungen aus dem bundestag
geschieht wo jeder abgeordnete nach
seinem gewissen entscheiden
was bedeutet überhaupt impfpflicht was
macht das mit ungeimpften was macht es
mit geimpften also welche auswirkungen
hat so eine entscheidung auf unsere
gesellschaft darüber wollen wir heute
abend diskutieren
und deshalb können sie uns gerne ihre
fragen und ihre statement schicken gerne
per mail oder in die kommentarspalten
schreiben wir sehen schon die
psychologin und verhaltensökonomen
doktor kathrin schmelzer wird uns heute
abend antworten geben und dann holen wir
später auch noch professor alexander
thiele in die runde er ist
rechtswissenschaftler aber erstmal guten
abend frau schmelz guten abend frau
schmitz menschen die sich nicht impfen
lassen wollen bis zum heutigen tage ist
das möglicherweise ein schlag mensch der
generell auf so ein wort pflicht sehr
allergisch reagiert also das ist erst
mal nicht ein schlag mensch sondern das
ist eine ganz bunte mischung an menschen
da gibt es natürlich diejenigen die
sagen meine pflicht kommt dann erst
recht nicht also dass da so eine
trotzreaktion kommt aber das sind auch
ganz viele andere menschen die angst
haben die sich unsicher sind die sich
auch vor der pandemie schon im stich
gelassen gefühlt haben und deswegen der
politik nicht vertrauen also das gibt
ganz ganz viele beweggründe
die neue regierung sagt sie will bis
weihnachten 30 millionen menschen impfen
erstimpfungen zweitimpfung dritt
impfungen und johanna sagt meister
bringt uns jetzt erstmal auf den
aktuellen stand der dinge in impfungen
mindestens 57 millionen menschen sind
laut lka in deutschland vollständig
gegen korona geimpft das sind 68,6
prozent der gesamtbevölkerung
deutschlandweit gibt es allerdings große
regionale unterschiede
bremen führt mit einer impfquote von
80,2 prozent
darauf folgen das saarland und hamburg
in sachsen liegt die impfquote mit 58,2
prozent am niedrigsten
weitere schlusslichter brandenburg und
thüringen mit rund 62 prozent
doch es tut sich was deutschlandweit hat
die zahl der erste impfungen zuletzt
wieder zugenommen so kletterte die zahl
vergangenen donnerstag auf 119.000 36
mehr erst impfungen zählte das rk ii
zuletzt am ersten september
wenn wir in unseren chat schauen dann
sieht man schon dass die meinung da
durchaus auseinander gehen isegrim
schreibt es wird zeit für eine
impfpflicht wir haben schon viel zu
lange gezögert frau schmelz können sie
sich vorstellen dass möglicherweise
schon allein die ankündigung einer
impfpflicht dann doch den einen oder den
anderen dazu bringt sich jetzt schon
dafür zu entscheiden
das kann ich nicht sagen aber ich könnte
kurz darauf eingehen was die
zuschauerinnen gesagt hat also ich
glaube ich kann mir gut vorstellen oder
kann gut verstehen dass viele die nase
voll haben und endlich wollen dass das
ein ende nimmt aber es war auch in
deutschland richtig lange die impfung
freiwillig zu lassen denn wir haben von
anfang an von anfang der pandemie an die
impfbereitschaft untersucht und immer
gesehen dass die freiwillige
impfbereitschaft viel höher war als die
bereitschaft unter einer impfpflicht das
heißt hätte man schon frühzeitig die
impfpflicht eingeführt hätte man viel
mehr gegen ihren willen impfen lassen
müssen impfen müssen als das eben jetzt
der fall wäre
und würden sie dann sagen dass jetzt der
richtige zeitpunkt ist um eine
impfpflicht einzuführen also die
situation hat sich drastisch geändert
natürlich also die freiwillige ins
bereitschaft die wir von beginn an
gesehen haben schon bevor der impfstoff
da war hätte gereicht um die alpha welle
die mit der alpha variante umzugehen
aber jetzt mit delta und nikon sieht es
einfach ganz anders aus und wenn die
biologen und virologin sagen wir müssen
die impflücken fast vollständig
schließen dann kommen wir wahrscheinlich
nicht an einer impfpflicht vorbei zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt
wir haben hat den magdeburg mal rum
gefragt wie eine impfpflicht denn
ankommen würde da würden wir gern mal
reinschauen ja ich finde es und jeder
gewicht werden damit jeder seine
freiheiten bekommt das ist das
wichtigste in den pflegeberufen und
drucken wo halt leute viel kontakt mit
menschen haben sich schon richtig aber
auch das herz natürlich heute überzeugt
nicht so richtig auf das der richtige
weg ist also ich finde die allgemeine
impfpflicht sehr gut ich bin dafür dass
die eingeführt wird weil ich der meinung
bin dass wenn es darum geht also um die
allgemeinheit geht dann sollte
eigentlich jeder tun was er tun kann um
nicht verirren jemanden aus in dieser
lage in dieser pandemischen lage solche
fahrzeuge ich muss sagen ich finde es
schwierig den leuten aufzuzwängen aber
wenn einem jahr immer noch hier stehen
und sagen die zahlen gehen jeden tag
100.000 infektion hoch und es sterben
jeden tag 100 menschen
dann könne man darüber reden aber es
dürfte nicht einfach eingeführt werden
ohne dass man vorher den leuten versucht
ist wirklich beizubringen was die
impfung bringt
das dann jetzt menschen auf der straße
die bereit waren ihre meinung zu uns in
die kamera zu sagen und weil das
natürlich jetzt nicht repräsentativ ist
schauen wir uns vielleicht noch mal ganz
kurz das zdf-politbarometer an da hat
sich die stimmung zur allgemeinen
impfpflicht im vergleich zum sommer
deutlich verändert schauen wir auf die
zahlen im aktuellen politbarometer vom
vergangenen freitag haben sich 69
prozent für eine impfpflicht
ausgesprochen 29 prozent dagegen im juli
waren noch 64 prozent gegen eine
impfpflicht und
33 prozent dafür das heißt es hat sich
einfach mehr oder weniger gedreht also
fast 70% schmelz sind dafür reicht das
als zustimmung für eine impfpflicht um
gewissermaßen einen gesellschaftlichen
frieden dann auch herbeizuführen und zu
wahren
das glaube ich nicht aber da geht es gar
nicht um die größenordnung von 70
prozent sondern wir sind diejenigen die
nicht geführt worden und das sind eben
eher diejenigen die selbst geimpft sind
unter den ungeimpften gibt es nur einen
sehr geringen anteil die einem
pflichtgefühl worden und das ist
eigentlich die relevante größe aber es
die wichtige frage ist eigentlich auch
gar nicht befürworten jetzt die
ungeimpften die impfpflicht oder nicht
sondern die frage ist zum einen wie
kommen wir aus der pandemie endlich raus
natürlich aber die andere frage ist auch
wände im pflicht eingeführt wird was
muss man tun um sie eher
akzeptiert zu haben
und was müsste man da tun ja also wir
sehen in unseren untersuchungen dass
eine impfpflicht nicht die aufklärung
ersetzt
haben beobachtet dass über den
zeitverlauf weil wir immer die gleichen
menschen verfolgt haben das über den
zeitverlauf die menschen in ihrer
haltung zur impfung ändern und menschen
die von einem zeitpunkt zum nächsten von
impfgegnern zu impfbefürworter sogar
unter einer impfpflicht werden die
werden das weil sie ihre überzeugung
geändert haben in der zwischenzeit kann
man sich anschauen welche überzeugungen
sind das um zu wissen an welchen
überzeugungen
ansetzen muss das ist zum einen der
glaube an die wirksamkeit der impfung
und auch die überzeugung dass die
impfung wirkt um die pandemie zu enden
das zweite ist das vertrauen in die
regierung also wenn menschen zwischen
zwei erhebungszeitpunkt vertrauen in die
regierung verloren haben haben sie ihre
impfbereitschaft verloren aber auch die
akzeptanz einer impfpflicht
und insofern ist das ein zentraler punkt
der natürlich schwierig ist weil eben
das viel oftmals menschen sind die
sowieso schon kein vertrauen in die
regierung haben es gibt noch zwei
weitere aspekte an denen man ansetzen
kann das eine ist das gefühl von
freiheit also wenn jemand das glaubt die
impfpflicht schränkt die freiheit ein
dann würde sich dagegen stellen und wenn
man die überzeugung ändert und versteht
dass die impfpflicht dazu dient dass
alle ihre freiheiten wieder gewinnen
können und ein ganz normales leben
wieder führen kann dann bringt das er
unterstützung und die bewegung für
die
impfbereitschaft und ein anderer aspekt
ist noch die wahrnehmung der aktuellen
situation also menschen die die aktuelle
lage kritischer wahrnehmen im
zeitverlauf werden auch von impfgegnern
unter einer impfpflicht er zu imz
befürwortern
sharing schreibt uns jetzt ist ja auch
ein problem dass der impfstoff
möglicherweise für omicron nicht so
wirksam ist
warum sollten wir uns dann mit dem alten
impfstoff impfen lassen wenn der nicht
so wirksam sein sollte ist das dann auch
noch mal etwas was das vertrauen in die
impfstoffe nicht gerade fördert und was
das dann nochmals schwieriger macht
diese menschen die sie gerade
angesprochen haben zu überzeugen ich
denke das ist ein wichtiger punkt denn
ja das ist ja gerade die diskussion
inwieweit wirken die impfstoffe nach die
virologen sagen die sind immer noch
sinnvoll um vor schweren verläufen zu
schützen weil sie eben weil die t-zellen
ja trotzdem anspringen und nicht
unbedingt die antikörper die an diesem
mutierte stelle ansetzen würden aber
eben diese kommunikation es ganz ganz
wichtig weil da das vertrauen gerade
sicher wackelt ich werde gerne an dieser
stelle jetzt herrn professor alex der
thiele dazu holen
und wo es ja kommt jetzt in hallo guten
abend herr thiele
sie werden uns die diskussion jetzt
bitte mal von einer rechtlichen seite
aus einordnen vielleicht zunächst einmal
wie würde denn so eine impfpflicht eine
allgemeine impfpflicht überhaupt
funktionieren
naja so eine allgemeine impfpflicht
würde eben wenn man sich das so
vorstellen möchte wie so eine art
ordnungswidrigkeit eingeführt das heißt
es würde erstmal die verpflichtet
begründet in gesetz das würde einem
gesetz passieren das also jeder ab einem
bestimmten alter bei den zugelassenen
impfstoffen mit den relevanten ausnahmen
also natürlich müssen sich nicht die
leute impfen die es nicht vertragen dass
all diese menschen aber die den
impfstoff gut vertragen medizinisch sich
also bis zu einem bestimmten stichtag
impfen lassen müssen gleichzeitig
müssten natürlich dafür sorge getragen
werden das ist ausreichend im angebote
gibt es ausreichend impfstoff da ist
aber dann würde man beispielsweise
festlegen dass also eine solche
impfpflicht etwa ab dem ersten märz 2022
besteht und bis dahin also jeder dafür
sorge zu tragen hat geimpft zu sein
es gibt hier direkt eine frage sie haben
das schon mal eben angesprochen aber
vielleicht können wir das noch mal ein
bisschen auf den punkt bringt hier hieß
es hallo was ist mit den menschen die
nicht geimpft werden können sei es durch
eine allergie oder krankheiten die diese
impfung verhindern die
selbst sei kämpft beziehungsweise
gewusst hat sie arbeitet aber in der
pflege und hat kollegen denen es so geht
die müssen dann nicht geimpft werden
sagte sie sagten sie leben
nein natürlich nicht also solche
menschen und personen die also aus
medizinischen gründen nicht geimpft
werden können die müssen natürlich auch
einer solchen pflicht nicht nachkommen
das würde im gesetz auch entsprechend
vorgesehen allerdings muss ich auch
gleich dazu sagen natürlich müsste das
dann auch medizinisch verifiziert werden
also die schlichte behauptung dass man
medizinisch nicht verträgt reicht nicht
auch religiöse gründe werden
wahrscheinlich nicht ausreichen um etwa
eine impfpflicht von sich zu weisen
als sie reden wir wirklich von einem
sehr kleinen personen preis aber
selbstverständlich sind diese personen
dann ausgenommen alles andere wäre
verfassungsrechtlich nicht möglich
jetzt ist es ja so dass es im
infektionsschutzgesetz schon allein
bereits eine passage gibt zu
verpflichtenden impfungen ich kann das
mal kurz vorlesen das bundesministerium
für gesundheit wird ermächtigt durch
rechtsverordnungen mit zustimmung des
bundesrats anzuordnen das bedrohte teile
der bevölkerung an schutzimpfungen oder
anderen maßnahmen der spezifischen
prophylaxe teilzunehmen haben wenn eine
übertragbare krankheit mit klinisch
schweren verlaufsformen auftritt und mit
ihrer epidemischen verbreitung zu
rechnen ist wäre damit die
impfpflicht gegen das corona virus schon
abgedeckt
nein jedenfalls keine allgemeine
impfpflicht sie zitieren glaube ich wenn
ich mich recht entsinne § 20 absatz 6
des innovations- lassen sie mal schauen
wo tatsächlich ja das muss man sich wohl
tatsächlich eine impfpflicht
eine impfpflicht möglichkeit vorgesehen
ist für die bundesregierung auf dem
verordnungswege aber wenn man genau dies
geht es da nur an bestimmte
bevölkerungsgruppen aus meiner sicht und
die wird geteilt von vielen starts und
verfassungsrechtlern wäre also die
einführung einer allgemeinen pflicht auf
dem verordnungswege nicht möglich wir
müssten dann schon das
infektionsschutzgesetz auch noch mal
ändern das ist ja auch das was im
augenblick geplant ist dass also der
gesetzgeber das parlament über diese
frage nicht nur diskutiert sondern sie
dann auch mit mehrheit entscheidet und
das infektionsschutzgesetz ändert also
der 20 absatz 6 reicht nicht aus um eine
allgemeine impfpflicht einzuführen aus
meiner sicht jetzt hat er gestern das
bundesverfassungsgericht entschieden
dass die freiheitsbeschränkungen im
frühjahr also zb die ausgangs
beschränkungen oder die
schulschließungen
rechtens und damit in ordnung waren gibt
diese entscheidung der politik jetzt
nochmal ordentlich rückenwind für diese
impfpflicht
knox rückenwind ist darüber kann man
sich streiten jedenfalls gibt es der
politik jetzt sozusagen den ball wieder
in die hand
und das bundesverfassungsgericht hat
eben festgelegt und entschieden dass die
effektive bekämpfung der pandemie
tatsächlich von der politik vornehmlich
vorzunehmen ist das grundgesetz gibt
hier einen großen spielraum für die
politischen entscheidungsträger der
letztlich aber auch belastend wirken
kann ich glaube wir sehen dass ein
bisschen jetzt auch bei der fdp denn man
kann eben dann nicht mehr auf das
grundgesetz verweisen und bestimmte
maßnahmen einfach pauschal ausschließen
sondern man trägt jetzt als politiker
als politikerin verantwortung für das
was man tut aber auch für das was man
unter lässt denn beides ist möglich und
dann muss man sich dieser politischen
verantwortung auch stellen und kann sie
nicht an das grundgesetz abstreifen
fabian schreibt auf youtube höhere
krankenkassenbeiträge für nicht geimpfte
also erzählt darauf ab dass eben nicht
geimpfte die dann eben auch ein stück
weit für die situation in den
krankenhäusern
zuständig sind und möglicherweise auch
verantwortlich sind eben dann zur kasse
gezogen werden sollen wer sowas
überhaupt rechtlich denkbar herr thiele
also das ist eine klassische
differenzierung zwischen geimpften und
ungeimpften und prinzipiell würde ich
eine solche differenzierung auch
zulassen juristisch also dass wir etwa
auch bei 2g haben wir ja so eine
differenzierung also deren dem recht ist
eine solche differenzierung erstmal
nicht fremd ob es auch bei den
krankenkassenbeiträgen ginge müsste man
im einzelnen prüfen ist ja unglaublich
ein logistischer und
verwaltungstechnische aufwand das dann
durchzuführen wie gehen sie mit leuten
um die sich zwischen zwei phasen
irgendwie impfen lassen und beweisen sie
dass nach also prinzipiell würde ich
aber sagen das würde wahrscheinlich
gehen aber es wäre extrem schwierig das
irgendwie umzusetzen
es ist jetzt nun nicht das erste mal das
ist für deutschland eine impfpflicht
geben soll das gab es in der
vergangenheit immer mal wieder und da
gab es auch immer wieder widerstand
dagegen das schauen wir uns kurz seien
im krieg 1870 71 preußen gegen
frankreich kam es zu einer großen
brocken epidemie die konsequenz
1874 wurde im deutschen kaiserreich eine
pflicht zur impfung gegen pocken
erlassen die erste impfung im zweiten
lebensjahr die wiederholungs impfung im
zwölften
mit solchen schock fotos machten
impfgegner mobil von gift war die rede
von selbstheilung und gesunder
lebensführung die impfgegner hielten
kongresse ab etwa 1911 in frankfurt am
main organisierten sich in vereinen
trotzdem über dauerte die impfpflicht
den lauf der zeit die republik von
weimar und auch den nationalsozialismus
erst jahrzehnte später als die welt für
pocan frei erklärt wurde endete auch die
impfpflicht in der jungen bundesrepublik
kam es abgesehen von der pockenimpfung
nur ganz vereinzelt zu regionalen im
verpflichtungen in der brd setzte man
auf freiwilligkeit
anders in der ddr hier galt impfen als
teil der staatsräson seit anfang der
60er jahre galt für etliche krankheiten
eine impfpflicht schon früh gegen ttc
dann gegen diphtherie tetanus polio
keuchhusten später gegen masern
1961 gab es in der ddr noch vier fälle
von polio in der brd vor allem im
ruhrgebiet erkranken dagegen tausende
hunderte starben dass deutschland hatte
auf einen impfstoff gesetz der injiziert
werden musste das wollten viele nicht
im osten gab es die schluckimpfung die
ddr bot der brd 3 millionen impfdosen an
der ersten diente ab aber auch hier
stellte man bald auf schluckimpfung um
mit einem serum aus dem westen
in den 70er und 80er jahren hatte die
ddr in sachen immunisierung wohl die
nase vorn auch wenn das impfen in ost
und west nur schwer vergleichbar ist
das impfen wurde im vereinigten
deutschland in die praxen der
niedergelassenen ärzte verlagert
verschwand aus den gesundheitsämtern das
hat die impf situation in deutschland
unübersichtlicher gemacht
frau schmelz wenn es jetzt um die
einführung einer impfpflicht in
deutschland geht was kann die politik
aus der vergangenheit lernen
dass es schwierig ich glaube wir müssen
eben die aktuelle situation wirklich
anschauen und aus der aktuellen
situation lernen und da ja
versprechen einhalten die man macht und
nicht so viel versprechen solche
diskussionen nicht führen ja die man
vielleicht dann wieder verwerfen muss
ich glaube solche sachen sind aktuell
eher wichtig und herr thiele frage an
sie was passiert denn jetzt wenn sich
jemand ganz ganz strikt weigert sich
impfen zu lassen und diese impfpflicht
dann eingeführt ist also zunächst gibt
es ein bußgeld aber wie weit kann das
eskalieren
na ja es kann so weit eskalieren wie das
bei bußgeldern eigentlich immer
eskalieren kann also diese bußgelder
sind natürlich vollstreckung das heißt
man würde dann versuchen dann
möglicherweise dinge zu finden aber im
schlimmsten fall kann eben auch die
ersatzkraft in diesem fall angeordnet
werden wenn man sich eben weigert sich
zu impfen das ist aber nichts was jetzt
spezifisch für die impfpflicht gilt
sondern das gilt generell das ist
einfach der normale vollstreckung sweg
was aber nicht
ist das also man irgendwie von der
polizei abgeholt dann zum arzt gebracht
und dann eben gegen seinen willen
wirklich die impf wird das war diese
sorge muss also keiner haben aber es
könnte durchaus teuer werden das mit
sicherheit genau das müssen wir
vielleicht noch mal ganz deutlich sagen
denn das wäre ja dann quasi ein
impfzwang und den soll es ja nicht geben
dass jemand gewaltsam eine spritze in
den arm berg bekommt das soll so nicht
passieren
das soll so nicht passieren das wäre
jedenfalls in der gegenwärtigen
situation verfassungsrechtlich
unzulässig ich würde die situation
könnte anders sein wenn wir von einem
virus reden was irgendwie eine
mortalitätsrate von 70 oder 80 prozent
hat oder ein schlimmes ebola-virus was
uns heimsucht und eine impfung gibt die
uns alle retten kann aber in der korona
pandemie ist ein solcher weg der
zwangsimpfung verfassungsrechtlich
ausgeschlossen
ich würde gerne noch ein paar meinungen
aus dem netz jetzt vorlesen und zwar
schreibt zum beispiel tom
bin geimpft aber impfpflicht geht zu
weit jeder soll das selbst entscheiden
martin sagt ich bin dafür wer sich
weigert soll ein bußgeld in höhe von
5000 euro bezahlen michaela schreibt auf
facebook längst überfällig dieses ewige
nervige gejammer und rumgeeiere muss mal
ein ende haben frau schmelz machen sie
sich gedanken oder sorgen dass der druck
der jetzt damit auch auf ungeimpfte
gemacht wird dann noch weiter umschlagen
könnte in proteste aggression gewalt die
es ja auch in der vergangenheit schon
gegeben hat das wird mit sicherheit
passieren bei einem teil der ungeimpften
aber sicher nicht bei allen also manche
werden sagen dass die pflicht und jetzt
mache ich das also das sehen wir auch in
unseren untersuchungen dass leute dann
doch sagen okay jetzt lasse ich mich
impfen wenn es verpflichtend ist aber
bei einem teil würde es natürlich
widerstand verstärken verschärfen und
die aggression werden sich kanalisieren
im protesten aber auch darin dass man
sich weniger an andere maßnahmen hilft
hält und dass man auch zukünftig an
anderen gesellschaftlichen problem
vielleicht weniger bereit ist zu
kooperieren aber gleichzeitig muss man
natürlich auch daran denken dass man das
vertrauen
aller menschen bewahren muss die sich
impfen lassen haben und die jetzt
einfach nur noch ein ende der situation
wollen absolut und da würde ich gerne
auch noch mal einen haken weil wir reden
ja wahnsinnig viel über die ungeimpften
und manchmal kommen da die geimpften die
fallen fast so ein bisschen hinten
runter obwohl die sich ja in der
pandemie schon allein durch die tatsache
dass sie sich impfen haben lassen sehr
kooperativ gezeigt haben und deren
geduldsfaden ja dann auch irgendwann
reißen wird und die dann auch das
vertrauen in die politik verlieren
ist das nicht auch ein argument für eine
impfpflicht frau schmelz dass die
politik ist den geimpften menschen auch
ein stückweit schuldig ist das
einzuführen damit man endlich aus dieser
pandemie rauskommt also ich denke die
meisten geimpften erwarten dass das
jetzt ein ende nimmt und dass wir
irgendwie gut über den winter kommen und
ja normales leben wieder haben können ob
man die impfpflicht schuldig ist oder
nicht das hängt so ein bisschen davon ab
wie man die impfpflicht wirklich umsetzt
und ob man sie wirklich durchsetzen kann
dann solche diskussionen um noch mal auf
den punkt von vorhinein zu gehen höhere
krankenkassenbeiträge das kann auch
einfach dazu führen dass man sich die
nicht impfungen kauft quasi dann zahle
ich eben mehr gebühren dann habe ich
meinen anteil geleistet und muss mich
nicht impfen lassen also man muss
wirklich gut überlegen wie man eine
impfpflicht durchsetzt um das vertrauen
bewahren zu können dann wenn sie kommt
und man kann sie nicht umsetzen und es
gibt zu viele ungeimpfte die sich dann
vielleicht einen gefälschten pass
besorgen und munter unter die geimpften
menschen dann hilft das dem vertrauen
der geimpften sicher auch nicht er habe
mir einen kommentar von monday an alle
die sich noch gegen die impfung sträuben
hier im chat bitte tut mir und meinen
kollegen den gefallen und geht euch
impfen die arbeitsbelastung mit corona
patienten ist wirklich extremst oder der
dickkopf spricht noch ein anderes thema
an auf youtube die politik müsste mehr
stationen für das impfen errichten die
warte- und stehzeiten sind teilweise
unzumutbar teilweise bekommst du für
diesen monat keine termine mehr da soll
sich jetzt auch noch mal was dran ändern
natürlich hat noch mal eine frage an sie
was gehört dieses auffrischen von
impfungen gehört das dann auch zu
allgemeinen pflicht künftig dazu
naja ich meine am ende gibt uns
juristische touristen auch die
wissenschaft den weg natürlich vor und
die impfpflicht ergibt natürlich nur
dann sinn wenn sie
immunologisch auch ihrerseits sinn
ergibt und wenn wir jetzt von den
immunologen und immunologen hören dass
also der impfschutz nach etwa sechs
monaten jedenfalls drastisch nachlässt
und dann irgendwann sogar gänzlich
aufhört dann wäre natürlich auch dafür
sorge zu tragen dass der impfschutz dann
bleiben kann und bleiben muss und das
wäre dann auch durch die impfpflicht
sicherzustellen das heißt auch die
booster impfung käme dann dazu was
allerdings nicht heißt dass jetzt sofort
schon gebucht werden muss aber die
politik muss diese sache natürlich auf
dem schirm haben und darf sie einfach
nicht ignorieren denn am ende hätten wir
dann nach einem dreiviertel jahr ja im
grunde einfach wieder nur 100%
ungeimpfte wenn wir darauf keine
rücksicht nehmen
rosel ihn hat noch eine frage auf
youtube ich weiß jetzt nicht ob sie
gerade insgeheim rechnen ist es geht
noch mal um die bußgelder und zwar fragt
sie und wie oft muss man strafe zahlen
wenn man sich nicht impfen lässt
ja das kommt ein bisschen drauf an wie
clever man sich der prüfung entzieht
wahrscheinlich also wie oft müssen sie
strafe zahlen wenn sie nie die
gurtpflicht einheiten im auto also immer
wenn sie erwischt werden möglicherweise
es könnte aber auch durchaus eine
regelung vorgesehen sein dass man
monatlich möglicherweise hier für jeden
monat was zahlen muss also da ist
tatsächlich
relativ viel denkbar auch was die
durchsetzung was die bußgeldhöhe angeht
es kann aber sehr sehr teuer werden
gerade im wiederholten vorstoß also das
allgemeine verwaltungsvorschrift recht
ohne dass ich jetzt sagen möchte dass
das hier gleich zur anwendung käme sieht
bußgelder bis zu 25.000 euro vor also
ich glaube nicht dass es sich wirklich
ernsthaft lohnt oder dass man sich
sinnvollerweise darauf einstellt dass
man sich das schon leisten kann also der
weg sollte schon sein das möchte ich
auch noch mal sagen dass die impfpflicht
dann auch vielleicht sind ein pflicht
bewusstsein führt wir geben in einer
gemeinschaft geben uns gemeinschaftlich
regeln so funktioniert gesellschaft und
auch die impfpflicht gehöre dann dazu
sie ist verfassungsrechtlich
zu lässig und als solche sollte man sie
dann auch akzeptieren weil wir alle doch
in einer gesellschaft leben wollen
alleine auf der insel das jedenfalls es
keine lösung das heißt wenn ich sie
richtig verstehe wäre das aus
juristischer sicht ein plädoyer für die
einführung einer helmpflicht
naja es ist weniger aus juristischer
sicht vielleicht spreche ich auch
weniger als jurist als jurist kann ich
ja nur sagen was erlaubt ist ich stelle
jedenfalls fest nach eingehender prüfung
dass sie möglich ist dass die
bundesregierung oder dann der bundestag
die möglichkeit hat sie einzuführen und
wenn ich jetzt als bürgerinnen und
bürger sprechen nicht mehr nur als
jurist dann würde ich sagen ja ich
plädiere ausdrücklich für die einführung
einer impfpflicht habe mich eben gerade
zufälligerweise mit einem monologen aus
göttingen professor dr jürgen wienern zu
unterhalten der auch noch einmal
deutlich gemacht hat wie wichtig es ist
sich zu impfen also als bürger bin ich
für eine impfpflicht als jurist sage ich
sie kann eingeführt werden
tobias schreibt auf facebook meine
mutter die nicht an corona erkrankt war
hatte vor zwei wochen ein intensiv bett
benötigt welches durch ungeimpfte corona
patienten belegt war sie ist am nächsten
tag gestorben
frau schmelz wir haben einen entwurf für
die beschlussvorlage für den bund länder
gipfel er morgen stattfinden soll
vorliegen und dann soll darüber
entschieden werden welche maßnahmen
jetzt in den nächsten wochen kommen und
da ist in dem beschlusspapier die rede
von einem akt der nationalen solidarität
kann man diese solidarität mit einer
verpflichtung zur impfung erreichen
ein stück weit schon also es gibt
studien die zeigen dass eine pflicht
enorm setzende soziale norm setzt und
ganz klar macht was das richtige ist und
eben stärker als eine freiwilligkeit mit
dringliche aufforderung insofern keine
pflicht tatsächlich zu solidarität
führen nicht bei allen aber ein stück
weit schon und impfpflicht wird ohne
frage die impfrate erhöhen
und damit möchte ich das gespräch
beenden vielen dank frau schmelz vielen
dank herr thiele ich wünsche ihnen noch
einen schönen abend
ja und morgen ab 11 uhr brad dann diese
bund länder runde von der ich gerade
gesprochen habe und dann sind wir
hoffentlich im laufe des tages schlauer
was in den nächsten wochen auf uns
zukommt und wir werden natürlich hier
dann auch darüber sprechen einen schönen
abend noch
[Musik]